as you look around the valley really
there's hardly an empty lot to be found
construction is booming especially up in
north las vegas
yeah an empty lot near a carry and
martin luther king boulevard will soon
hold retail spaces there's going to be
restaurants there
reporter kate houston breaks down the
businesses that are moving in and how
people in the area feel about it
homeowners in the area of carry and
revere will soon only have to walk down
the street
to enjoy the new restaurants and
businesses coming into this development
so far a nail salon and soul food
restaurant have signed a lease
agora realty is overseeing the project
and says a breakfast cafe and cell phone
company are also interested
really happy to hear that they're
finally building something there we'll
kind of
cut down on the noise and the street
traffic and stuff
pat meintz lives right behind the
development in this new subdivision
i'm very happy since it's right behind
me it'd be really nice having a place to
get my nails
and grab a bite to eat and
improvement to the to the area here
these renderings show spaces for parking
and
three large outdoor patios some of the
spaces will be restaurant ready
meaning the tenant will only need their
equipment and tables to open
even in the midst of a pending we issued
more building permits probably than any
entity
in the state of nevada councilwoman
pamela goins-brown says they're working
hard to develop these mature
areas of north las vegas basically no
services that are
where you don't have to get in your car
and drive more than two or three miles
away
just for basic things you know places to
eat or
servers type businesses so it's very
much needed
agora realty expects construction to be
done by this december or next january
kate houston 8 news now councilwoman
goins-brown says these new developments
are helping strengthen the north las
vegas economy
others are planned near kerry and losey
as well as again near kerry and martin
luther king boulevard brian